hi I'm Christine welcome to this talk as
a disclaimer I am one of the cofounders
of honeycomb and we practice what we
preach but the techniques talked about
in this talk should be applicable no
matter what tools you use so let's set
the scene quick question
only mandatory audience participation
innocent whole talk bear with me how
many of you identify primarily as DevOps
or infra or ups show of hands
okay how about okay mmm that's not for
me I primarily identify as a developer
okay good they'll be a little bit of
something for everyone my name is
Christine and I'm a developer when I
first started out that's young and
excited bright-eyed bushy-tailed I took
pride in being very fast at what I did I
could take a speck do all the
responsible things that the software
engineer did and commit and ship I could
do it over and over again and it
actually took me a few years and a
couple jobs before I interacted with my
first real ops person I met her because
I was working on a new component of a
system and that nice little rhythm had
gotten in in my first few years fast
moving and committing and moving on to
the next thing started to look a little
bit more like this there's a lot of door
knocking on metaphorical because this is
an open office but nor talking on and
frustration and I started to learn why
certain unflattering stereotypes of
engineering roles exist because I would
hear things like from the other side of
the room
cranky person having a deal with my code
going to production and breaking things
and I would get defensive and I'd be
like well you know it worked when I
wrote it so it's got to be your
production machines and as time went on
and my relationship with this awful
person improved it became clear that you
know after
there was a little piece of
responsibility that I did have to take
that often these small totally save
changes I was pushing to production were
causing some chaos out there in the wild
there was a really great medium post in
February published by an engineering
leader at Expedia where he analyzed
several hundred production incidents
went through all these post mortem
reports looking for not root causes
but triggers the things that caused an
incident to surface and this big orange
slice is change changing the code
sometimes change in the config or
infrastructure but change we've just
established who the agents of change
often are and on a macro level things
are changing around us right they like
very simple a nice neat lamp stack of
rails that rails is heyday
it's starting to look a little bit more
like the diagram on the right we've got
more pieces more interactions and as a
result the number of possible ways and
interaction might go badly and things
might break and so in this new more
complicated world this old pattern of
well devs write code and then they throw
it over the wall and ops folks have to
deal with it it starts to that model
starts to break down and the way the
thing that we're starting to have to see
is that these two sides of the wall have
to work together have to think about
well what happens when my code hits prod
well what sorts of things can we tell
the developers so that they write better
code in the first place and their code
works as well in production as on their
machines and so if the first wave of
DevOps was having ops folks learn to
code or automate their work the second
wave is going to have to be to support
this migration that we're already seeing
it's going to have to be to have
developers learn
to own their code in production out
there in the wild off of their own
machines and that little bridge between
the two the way we start to blur those
lines
it's observability for anyone who may
not be familiar with that term there is
an old school engineering definition you
can find out on Wikipedia there's lots
of cool stuff about it and how it helps
them things like space flight and our
modern software engineering world I like
to think of it as instead well being
able to ask questions like what's
happening with my software why is it
behaving in this way so okay wait if
developers are the ones causing all the
problems why are we setting them as a
protagonists of this story well a lot of
the right instincts are in place let's
take a look at you know standard ish
modern software development process
there's so much thought and curiosity
going in to make sure that we're writing
the right thing
a couple things might jump out at you
notably how many times the concept of
testing is introduced we do it over and
over again as the environment gets more
complicated as it goes from have nice
neat little unit tests all the way to
full integration tests we could also
argue this last one is also a form of
testing traditionally on the ops side of
the spectrum traditionally you know
where the office person is looking at
production saying this doesn't look
right but it actually shares a lot of
similarities with the testing that we do
in pre-production writing good
pre-production tests right is all about
thinking through scenarios thinking
about how our code should behave and
then investigating when it doesn't do
the thing that we thought then we're
practiced we get at this the better our
code gets because we're better at
thinking ahead explicitly stating our
assumptions for how our code should
behave but the static tests tend to run
in these nice little neat environments
cases don't change a whole lot
and so they cannot capture the
unpredictability of production of
real-world users malicious or otherwise
doing crazy things on our system and so
in order to extend this method of
comparing expected versus actual to
production we tend to look at things in
aggregate we're trying to look at things
at a high level but the concepts are
still there okay well I expect it to
look kind of flat and stable like this
when the actual jumps up why imagine
writing code expecting it to behave like
a miko and instead getting a rocket all
right we've got some investigating to do
to give you a sense of where we're
trying to go with this I have some
tweets from CJ CJ Silverio who put forth
an initiative recently within her
engineering team to prioritize
observability she did some great work
our team does some great work
instrumenting a legacy monolith and
suddenly realized what it was like to be
able to see and the main thing that she
heard is that this thing that people had
been scared to touch to make changes to
or to improve suddenly wasn't so scary
anymore the more you can see what's
actually happening with your code the
the lower that barrier entry feels and
that same thing happens between Devon
prod by embracing observability we can
we can start to see how the code that we
understand in this nice little sanitized
space paves out there and we can start
to plan for that as we write the code in
the first place if we look back at the
step process test-driven development was
the first you know movement that really
shortened that feedback loop back when
it was easy you know when you're writing
your code and it's easy to make changes
given how effective that was what if we
extend the dev process out to production
where we know it's going to go anyway
but see what learnings we can fold in as
we're writing the code before then
what if we shift that observe stage left
by folding observability into our
development process we can get this
really this beautiful virtuous cycle in
which we inform every stage of shipping
software and that's how developers get
to build up this off sensibility of I'm
writing this code and it smells like ooh
I should watch out for that case or I
should think about how it's going to
behave when that user touches it because
observability is more than just a set of
tools it's more than just having a
certain set of type it's more than
having a certain set of data it's about
the process and the culture of a team
practiced at looking at code all the way
through that cycle
okay so we're bought in hopefully we've
set the scene
we know the players now let's activate
our powers earlier when I talked about
observability I use a lot of verbs
understanding asking that's because just
having a tool or having graphs isn't
enough to let you do that powerful thing
same way having a Thor's hammer doesn't
actually make you Thor so sometimes
there are some things that we have to do
to really empower and give make it
easier for our developers to get
comfortable in production the first
thing is teach those production tools to
speak our language
when tool speak my language I mean
things like they respect the nouns that
I care about when I'm debugging or
analyzing code traditional monitoring
tools often assume a set of things that
don't actually tie back to what I deal
with day to day the concepts I deal with
in my code when I have that ops person
come at me frustrated because CPU right
you know CPU utilization is up on a
certain set of Cassandra nodes
doesn't actually tell me where to start
looking it doesn't help me map what
she's seeing
to what I need to fix tuned for the
situation contrast that instead to the
sorts of nouns that appear in my tests
in my day to day that actually triggered
different behaviors in the code itself
that aren't just symptoms but start to
be things that let me understand how to
reproduce understand how to let me tease
apart what's happening and imagine
instead of being yelled at about
Cassandra right through put I'm instead
told that the latest deploy seems to
impact seemed to increase latency for
our payments endpoint and is
significantly impacting our largest
customer oh okay now I start to
understand where to begin looking how to
begin reconstructing that repro and also
what its impact is how high cardinality
data support is also important for
anyone who may not be familiar high
cardinality refers to having lots of
possible values for a given type of data
and these if these were the nouns I deal
with day to day all these are high
cardinality all these might have tons of
unique values and a lot of tools
traditional monitoring tools struggle to
support that but I need these in order
to slice and dice and really understand
well things are slow for this customer
things are slow for this endpoint under
these conditions grand this in reality
build ID doesn't really seem like a high
cardinality attribute it doesn't seem
like a unmanageable type of data but
it's constantly increasing there's
really no bounds on how many builds you
can ship but it matters so much day to
day in understanding the impact of my
code this is our dog food instance and
the question that our engineers have
encoded in as just one of the kind of
templates is
is my change out yet because they're
gonna understand the impact of their
code they need to know whether they've
changed has been shipped and if our cop
software is going to constantly evolve
and grow our instrumentation needs to be
able to grow along with it we expect
folks to keep their tests and
documentation up-to-date instrumentation
is just another form of expressing what
this code is doing
we know that the easier we make it to
write and run pre-production tests the
more folks will do it and the same is
true of instrumentation all of these
things lead to being more comfortable
looking at production thinking about
production always having that in your
mind of the extension of the development
process and in doing so allows
production to not feel like some dark
scary place so that your legacy monolith
doesn't feel like some impenetrable
thing that is you know behaving in a
strange way no no it's just part of how
we ship code and how we understand how
it behaves we talk a lot about nouns
speaking the language there are some
concepts that we can bring from
production into development as well to
make it feel more familiar tracing is
one of the most developer friendly
evolutions yet in this industry a lot of
people talk about like oh you know
distributed tracing it's great for
monolith sorry it's great for micro
services you know when you have
containers and kubernetes is important
that's cool that's true but it's also
great for just understanding what's
happening inside one service inside my
logic one look at a trace and you
immediately start to understand how it
maps to the structure of the code and
and how how it's executing someone
described tracing recently as Chrome
developer tools for non browser software
which feels a little silly but it's so
accurate right also you know teaches you
that none of these concepts are ever new
but how exciting that we can start to
connect these things that develop
are totally familiar with they
understand how to look at understand how
to work with to this production
environment where hey this thing that
you're used to be able to doing inside
your browser for this one request you
can now do for this thing that executed
in the wild for this user over there you
can see service boundaries you can see
function boundaries and once you have
that developer looking at happily
looking at a production trace thinking
about oh man okay they're just like some
weird some weird things that happen with
that user you've got them and you can
start to show them the overall impact
it'd be like oh yeah this thing that
you're looking at that happened in
production here's where it is relative
to everything else in production this
trace that we're looking at oh this is
unusually slow okay what can we learn
from it and understanding its impact in
production overall I also love tracing
because I feel like it's found a really
clever way to make logs tractable and
meaningful all devs know how to log
write printf hello world one of the
first things that we do whatever
language you prefer but adding a little
bit of tracing structure lets you start
to turn those log lines into something
that actually reflects the code which
then lets you which feeds into better
analytics which feeds into better
understanding of production
I feel like tracing is what happens when
logs grow up so okay what does this all
actually look like activated are our
powers we know they're developers how
does this virtuous cycle help me be
better at what I care about most which
is shipping code a few examples what
observability is our super power we can
use our understanding from production to
figure out what could write in the first
place
one of those problems known to software
right it's something slow all right
users complaining don't know why what's
slow is everything slow or something
slow for certain users or some things
slow in some parts of our system
in dev maybe you connect a profiler
maybe you connect a debugger or
something that that like hooks right
into your nice little neat sanitary
environment try to painstaking
painstakingly reproduce what the users
are seeing but if you have data flowing
from production if you're capturing
something about what users are actually
experiencing let's just go there and
take a look at what users are seeing at
that point it's just a matter of
starting from this high level signal
that something is up write some graph
that has an artifact where you like a
shouldn't shouldn't look like that start
a high level you zoom in and you zoom in
you sift apart Tuesday part that signal
from the noise you slice and dice until
you find something they go you know this
teo line that's behaving unusually let's
zoom in on that let's investigate I
produce the search space I as a
developer can start to understand what
cases are causing that slowness what I
am going to need to fix coming up and
then we zoom in we find an actual
example and we reiterate by being able
to do this slicing and dicing to be able
to base it on real production data we
can stop guessing right there's nothing
worse than spending a bunch of time
working on something deploying it and
not actually seeing it fix the issue so
by having the expectation be we look at
production we ground our assumptions in
reality we can make sure that we're
writing the right code in the begin with
what observability is our superpower not
just what but we know we can learn how
best to write that code in the first
place sometimes you get a simple ticket
right ah handled message JSON great easy
I can do that write the code write a
test case push it out but wait this is
actually what is your code going to do
what you actually wanted to do
how many users are using your system
right now and relying on the old
behavior well your new code impacts them
in a way that they want how many people
are actually using your system the way
that you expect being able to use
production data to understand what
normal is it's a hugely important part
of making sure that the code you ship
does what you expect or else maybe you
start unfurling a lot of JSON that
people didn't actually want unfurled
what if instead of jumping right in
writing that code writing the test and
shipping it what if we had a little bit
of instrumentation or what if we we
looked at production if it was already
instrumented to see how many people are
using how many people are sending us
Ness of JSON today how many people are
happy about that
instrumentation allows us to turn the
kind of data exhaust that our systems
output into these lightweight debug
statements it helps us understand what
the code is doing it along the way and
being able to do that in real time
having that flexibility to ask what's it
doing that's what helps us understand
what things are edge cases what things
are education that matter for our tests
and which edge cases are actually the
norm and our mental model of what people
are doing is mistaken occasionally I
have someone be like well that's what
product managers do and this is true
product managers do a lot of thinking
about what is normal and what users want
but often they're making their decision
and these are great assumptions I
apologize many product managers make
their decisions based on qualitative
interviews and grand intuition screw
that we're developers we have access to
production and we have real data when
observability is our superpower we can
look at production to figure out whether
our code is working and whether our code
will work
complex systems have an almost infinite
set of possible failure scenarios
possible but almost impossible
I forget more complex there the set of
those simply increases and so rather
than trying to predict each one of those
and immortalizing it in a test improve
in a pre-production environment by
embracing observability we are able to
make sure that if something happens we
find out about it immediately and we
have enough information to do something
about it to learn about it by tracking
the signals that we need at the top and
including the metadata that we need to
break it down we can tease apart the
interesting bits in real time and have
that feedback loop back into well I see
in the code how to reproduce this I can
see in the code how why it executed down
this path test in production has become
kind of a polarizing term for some folks
so first let me say when I say test in
production obviously also test
pre-production but what I love about the
phrase is that it's all about having
production be a test bed for hypotheses
for code that you're like oh this should
work but it might not work so let's make
sure our friends over at Geckoboard have
a great story where they're releasing
some they're working on a future that
essentially reduced down to the bin
packing problem
and like any np-hard or np-complete
problem it could have been something
that like their engineers like jumped on
and been like I'm gonna spend a couple
days coming up with the perfect
implementation of this you'll see but
instead they were like wait we can we
can test this let's come up with a
couple different implementations real
quick don't spend much time on them push
them all to production half production
traffic flowing over them then throw
away the result after capturing it
sort of observability tool where they
could slice and dice and quickly assess
which one's worked best on their
workload for their customers in reality
not just some hypothetical test
environment and they were able to do
that assess pick one all over the course
of a day because their tools supported
ad hoc experiments their culture was one
that wanted to be data-driven is dead
driven and their developers were
comfortable with the idea of production
as a testbed the idea of well I can't
simulate it I can't
I could there's only so much I can do
before production let's see what's
happening out there I my favorite part I
think of this particular superpower is
how well it pairs with other techniques
that people are adopting in this space
feature flags are great make it really
easy to test out code or a very specific
segment of your traffic there it's even
more powerful when you can take that
segmenting where you can take the values
that those feature flags are outputting
and shove them into your observability
tooling because then you can see your
top level metrics that you care about
latency throughput error rate whatever
you care about but also break it down by
whatever tiniest segments of folks are
flagged in that day example with this a
couple years ago we were well every time
we ship out something that is going to
have is going to touch very performance
sensitive part of our system we try to
ship it out behind a future flag right
so we we know perform a performance
sensitive part of our system there's a
lot of heterogeneous traffic we can only
simulate so many things and test we've
pushed it up very carefully to
production and we do a feature flag to
double check ok this change should have
no impact on performance we've flagged
in the this 3% of our users is that true
do our expectations match reality and we
can see
latency for folks flagged into the
experiment not flagged into the
experiment and have confidence that that
test code disliked almost there mostly
mostly covered but possibly problematic
code we can see for sure in production
great it's stable let's ship it to
return to a previous theme if the Marvel
Universe has taught us anything it's
that superheroes are better together
when we're trying to understand
something about our systems especially
if we're new to a team the best way is
always going to be hey hey how did you
do that how did you figure that out when
our best resources are teammates it's
it's because they have the context to
know what matters and what doesn't
they have the context to to look at a
graph and be like well wait break it
down by customer that customer they're
garbage we can blacklist them and
realistically I am just never going to
be as good at debugging the Kafka issue
as the ops person who's been dealing
with Kafka for the last five years but
if I can peek over their shoulder and if
practices tools processes make it easy
for me to borrow that knowledge it's a
whole lot better than trying to figure
it out myself and honestly let's face it
all debugging is social even if it's
just past you present you and feature
you sharing context like the little
notes to yourself or the little hints
about how to how to interpret a graph
that context is key when understanding
whether something matters but it's the
context of knowledge that lives in our
brains that takes data from being just
data to real answers a lot of the
techniques that we use in this industry
to transfer knowledge Docs and
post-mortems rely on active intent an
active knowledge transfer which is good
and important we should continue doing
those
but there's also it's also important
recognize the value of passive knowledge
transfer shadow ops slack bots are kind
of in this space but imagine if tools
the things that we're using allow us to
leave a paper trail for our future
selves or our teammates if I don't need
the resident [ __ ] expert to teach me
something and I can instead look through
their paper trail see how they resolve
some issue when they were on call last
week and allows them to show their work
without having to worry about me and me
being able to level up on my own time
I've heard engineers new to an on-call
rotation describe watching an
experienced on-call engineer like
watching someone make leaps of intuition
akin to magic but as we know from Arthur
Sze Clarke's third law sometimes all
that magic is is someone using a
sufficiently advanced technology and the
key for us is finding a way for folks to
use that technology in a way that is
learn about and shareable this is how we
build up our superhero team this is how
we lower the barrier to entry for
developers just getting comfortable in
production and this is how we bring
everyone up to the level of the best
debugger and now while we segue into the
obligatory Batman brooding over Gotham
City moment let's recap in the old world
devs cared about code in the development
and test environments and not scared
about prod but there are all sorts of
reasons to break down those barriers now
and empower devs to own their code
through production there's some concrete
things we on the dev and the ops side
should be doing to facilitate that and
we can take our learnings from
production and supercharge our
development process
and the best case honestly we skip the
extensive CGI battle this is where
reality deviates from Hollywood because
the whole purpose of this exercise is to
reduce that sort of tension and release
to reduce the number of times that we're
woken up in the middle of the night
because our code is misbehaving when we
fold observability into the development
process we can ship code more reliably
and more confidently because we know
that we've already thought through some
of the production cases because we've
already even tested it in production
because no one can live the ups and
downs of constant being on call
constantly being paged
constantly being pulled into battle and
the more that we can do to shift those
high-stress situation high-stress
situations from reactive behaviors into
proactive work that thinks through
expected versus actual the more we'll be
able to be resilient and do what we love
shipping good so for those folks in the
audience who raised their hands when I
asked whether you're an ops info dev ops
think about how you can empower your
dads to share in the great
responsibility and the great power think
about the tools and processes that let
developers start to build an
understanding of have this code I tested
this code I ship this code and then it
did this and then it behaved like that
and look for opportunities to show
developers the sorts of powers that they
can have and how observability can help
them even before they hit merge and if
you're a developer remember that these
superpowers are possible within your
grasp because we need to stop writing a
software based on our intuition or
someone else's intuition and start
grounding it in reality and backing it
up with data because we can all have
superpowers now when we look for
opportunities to get comfortable with
production we'll ship better code
deliver better experiences and
observability will will genuinely be how
we got there
I've got a little time I'd love to take
questions thank you for bring a great
audience
yes thank you the question was about
compliance and about what happened how
to facilitate its feedback cycle when
there are rules like des can touch prod
well what does touch prod mean right
okay question was how do we Automation
is the answer but how do we explain the
the difference between so we're not
touching prod well there's like I don't
know if this will go how this will go
with your compliance folks but there's
right vs. read right if they're worried
about the rights a lot of this
observability stuff a lot of this is
just read let's make sure that we have
ways to read what's happening and that
reading is what's important if we I feel
like if you can frame it in a way that
says like this reading of signals from
Howard Koh behaves lets us detect
problems sooner or prevent problems in
the first place like that has to be
something that they can get behind they
can they don't want they don't want
problems either they don't want there to
be issues either but there needs to be
that visibility into what's happening or
else you're relying on your users to do
that for you and no one wants that
question is how do we adapt these ideas
to a product where there isn't a lot of
meaningful production traffic it's not
about I think there's a perception that
these things are only these techniques
are only useful for super high volume
systems I don't think that's true I
think that for anything where you are
taking software that you deeply
understand and then putting it into an
environment where it might be used in a
way that you don't deeply understand
it's important to have that feedback
loop for how it is being used how it is
how people you know the inputs that
people are putting in a lot of folks
will say well you know I have exception
trackers for that and exception trackers
will tell me if someone did something
that I didn't expect which is true
insofar as everything you didn't expect
will throw an exception which isn't
always the case right I think that the
the thing the idea that I'm trying to
get in folks as heads here is that
feedback loops are necessary at every
stage they're necessary for your hobby
project that you're you know your
friends are using but I'd be using an
unexpected ways and they and that's and
you can create feedback loops back in
looping into every everything that you
do does that answer your question if you
ship a side project you should have
something that tells you whether people
are using it yep
question is how do you advocate for
instrumentation and environment where
it's thought of as a nice-to-have ha ha
ha
otherwise in his life yeah so can depend
right there are a few arguments I made
where I'm like well instrumentation is
like tests you like tests right we want
instrumentation that can go well they
might not by that I think it is and and
sometimes it's selling to your bosses
sometimes as an ops person it's selling
to the developers right developers don't
wanna be slowed down they don't add
instrumentation the argument I always
use is like well assuming you're not
starting from nothing like show them
what you can do when you get there show
them what you show them the value of oh
man if we add customer ID to this graph
we can immediately see this thing we can
immediately understand that this one
customer does this terrible thing all
the time or that things are slow but for
this one customer it's way slower there
and everyone else and and finding like
there's often a just a little bit that
we can do to speak in the language of
what they care about that that starts to
get some head nodding to be like oh ok
that's not so bad and there's also this
perception that instrumentation is like
a big heavy lift that must be done
correctly all the way through and it's a
whole project unto itself but that doesn
have to be the case either it should be
incremental it should be something that
evolves with the code that you're
shipping and the more that folks can get
in the mindset of oh well I'm writing
this new code join you to update Doc's
here's an instrumentation that I should
make sure matches this other stuff over
there again you start to get that
dopamine hit of you add a little bit of
instrumentation you use it for some
benefit and it gets ingrained into your
practice
what's most areas of questions to kind
of test
the question was if you were in a land
where you have some instrumentation you
have some tooling how do you how do you
gauge whether you're doing it right or
doing it well my question back to you is
like do you ever have outages or
incidents or questions where you're like
I don't know the answer it's which is a
very squishy answer to your question but
if you exist in an environment where
you've got some intrument ation usually
when you have questions about what's
happening in production you can answer
them in a way that is in actionable
awesome your set seems stable if you
have a lot of these tools and yet when
you have downtime you can't figure out
why or like you can't isolate it you
can't figure out where it's happening in
order to stop the bleeding those are
signals that something's something's not
right all right it's easy to have
especially this day and age it's easy to
have like five different tools that all
promise to do the same thing and yet
have none of them give you the answers
and one of the most frustrating things
from my past lives is like having a
graph and being like I see this but why
like tell me more and that feeling is is
one where there are a lot of really
great flexible tools out there that can
let you explore in a way that answers
your questions
the question was whether I think UAT is
a waste of time and I'm actually gonna
have to say I don't know what you I T
stands for you a to user acceptance test
do I think that's valuable it can that's
part of your that's part of your process
the thing that I love with in that is
the the idea that there are end-users
who are testing it not you know they
don't care about your unit test passing
they don't care about your functional
tests they care about their goals my
quote the thing I push back on there is
still is that going to get you coverage
in the way that you care about how did
you pick those users who are doing the
user acceptance testing how did you pick
the tape the cases that they're going to
be testing for it seems useful but it
still seems like it relies on a lot of
predicting what will matter and we're
moving towards a world where you just
can't anymore
so basically a decision for your team
whether you want to maintain that
environment or not and I think a trend
that we're sort of seeing is folks
getting rid of their staging
environments because they're just like
well we have the visibility that we need
in prod
we don't need staging anymore we don't
need this intermediate environment
because it's just overhead any other
questions oh yes sorry about that
thank you for that but the comment was
to add to the question of how do you
incentivize people to to care at
instrumentation or better their world
some teams put their developers on call
and that's something something that
we've seen as well by putting by Pete
and by putting the people who create the
problems on call for their own software
when you were woken up at 2:00 a.m. you
have to deal with figuring out why it's
happening absolutely yes
the additional comment was an addition
to putting developers on call putting
leaders on call when managers and
directors start to get paged start
observability and better tooling around
that also becomes a priority thank you
all right I will be around if anyone
else has questions otherwise please go
to lunch get fed thank you for being a
great audience
[Applause]